[Music]
who told me
the personification of aggression a true
Global Superstar the hottest property in
my time
[Applause]
shots
[Music]
what is up fam it is Monday morning nine
o'clock A.M on this beautiful crisp
Calabasas morning how's everybody doing
great
I like how chin answered I was talking
to the fans I said they can hear you
guys Chin's I'm actually all right you
know what that's been great
uh what's up man straight off the plane
almost said boat straight off the plane
from Houston Texas shot to H-Town had a
grand old timeout in H-Town man a really
good time love Texas Texas back to back
for your boy can't get enough for taxes
um a lot of tiger thick out there a lot
of tiger thick it's our biggest market
so I was meeting with specs and meeting
with Distributors your boy was working
even when he wasn't on stage but it was
a grand old time shot to everybody who
came out
um yeah the only bad thing is when you
do this stuff
um you know I couldn't
um watch the UFC 281 live uh obviously I
know what's going on because when we do
the meet and greet swimming fans that
come up to me like dude you see what
happened to Izzy I'm like thank you no I
didn't thank you so there's no way to
not hear about it so I was able to watch
it last night and once again this
morning
um so you know let's get right into UFC
281 hell of a card from top to bottom my
God there's finishes on finishes on
finishes especially on the main card all
finishes
um it's not just about the main card you
got uh McConnell was filthy Ryan Spann
with domic rays as we went into it I
told you guys you know for
a few people on the card there's some
make or break fights on this with Dan
hooker
um you know kicking off the main card he
had to really get a win I think it was
he lost his I think three out of five or
some crap like that so you know hooker
need to pull it off I thought hooker
looked phenomenal also yeah he's lost
four out of his last five so far okay
that was a big win you could tell how
relieved he was his post-fight speech
was a little strange you know he was
like what do you say he said
when you put the when I put the nail in
my mouth it's like butter or something
like that you're like all right well
that must be a Australian thing a New
Zealand thing because in America like
okay
um like just Rogue which was cool the
dude that he fought uh uh Claudio uh
well let's
obviously uh uh Jiu Jitsu master and was
had hooker in some compromised positions
but
a pretty good fight for hooker even
though uh pules was on a streak there is
a TaylorMade fight for hooker like I was
you know scooting on his butt dragging
his ass not really how you want to kick
the main card off but at least hooker
got him out of there in the second round
those uh body kicks he looked phenomenal
hookah looked really really good
um glad he got a win especially with
everything he's been dealing with with
you know the immigration the New Zealand
the covert protocols and basically doing
an underground Fight Club to get ready
for these fights because they were so
strict in New Zealand and Australia so
he's been away from his family so from
one dad to another I was really rooting
for Dan hooker
um you know so the big takeaways were
for Dan hooker huge fight make or break
it for his career also Dominic Reyes who
didn't
um have as good as luck he got knocked
out
you know he did it was a jab I know
people like oh his chin but the problem
is it's his momentum he was coming
forward so that makes turns that jab
based into just a hard straight left you
know so his momentum was coming in first
round is a fighting a hot second
tough go for her man tough freaking go
and the other one you know and I'm not
sure why the UC did this match up but in
uh Blanche field responding with tan uh
our homegirl meatball there
she was a big dog on this fight you know
she had some real momentum so the hype
train got completely derailed
um you know she got dealt with she got
really dealt with
um so you know it was a rough night for
Dominic Reyes and uh Molly the meatball
also Brad riddle you know he was a good
fight though
um my boy Andre petrovski I told you
guys my lock for the fight card you know
he's a pretty sizable favorite uh
absolutely mopped the floor with homeboy
called out Beau nickel which I think is
interesting he's been calling him for a
while now too I know yeah I know he's
like you finish yourself a wrestler come
get it that'd be an interesting fight
even grappling matches he wants to do
I'm down for that you know for Bo nickel
would be a good a good task for him so
you know we you know we think he's a top
five middleweight and uh
petrovsky's no punk man so I would be
open to it I think the UFC would be open
to it too because for Bo Nick you can't
just toss in the top 10 guy you know
there's some sort of
you know protocol here yeah Oxford says
shut your mouth but there is some sort
of protocol here so under patrols could
be up
for anybody else getting to the UFC you
know with their first fight they would
never toss you a guy like Andre
petrovski he's a nightmare for you the
only knock and Andre you know I
absolutely love you maybe cardio there
but also man Square Garden big fight
that might have something to do with it
you probably got tired more exhaust from
beat the [ __ ] out of this guy so that
could have something to do with it so it
it was basically a Flawless Victory this
is Mortal Combat you know Flawless the
only I'm trying to the only thing you
pick out is maybe a cardio issue there
but I'm not saying an issue but you know
maybe instead of a 10 out of 10 I give
you 8 out of ten that's it that's it but
yeah you probably got tired from
whooping his ass I get it man I get it
uh to kick off the freaking early
prelims Jesus Christ I watched this this
morning that Carlos oldberg my God what
a way to kick it off at mask regarding
Massacre Garden just brings the best out
of guys it just you know it's Massacre
Garden Muhammad Ali fought there the
who's who the classic boxing fights
there you know it's the Knicks who are
terrible but still we still people still
are obsessed with them in New York even
though they just always suck big wiener
but um yeah I don't like the next and
what sucks is kith this is because Jack
kiss with my probably my favorite brand
and because they're New York brand they
they make the clothes for the Knicks if
they worked with any other team I could
rock it but it's just the bright orange
you know the bright orange and black
it's like so Halloween all the time and
then when I go to New York they drop
this new jacket I was like oh it'd be
dope to win New York I'll go to New York
next year but it's like you're only you
can't wear that around L.A you know I'm
the first thing from you I love New York
absolutely love it not a big Knicks fan
they never do anything to get their [ __ ]
together ever
ever just uh draft that Jr guy I won't
get into basketball for yesterday or
Barrett
um but back UFC 281 so the whole card
was gangbusters man gangbusters felt bad
for meatball like I said felt really bad
for Thomas Reyes he's in a tough
position you guys see what the UFC is
going to do with him are they going to
cut him he is a light heavyweight so
they're giving him a little bit of a
longer leash especially
I think what's tough for him and he
talked about in the prelim he talked
about the the pre-fight interviews and
then I want to say maybe in the post
fights with the Jon Jones stuff like
hey bro that was two years ago we got we
got to move on you didn't win the fight
you know uh so let's get to the main
card even though we just dabbled in Dan
hooker uh the guy who absolutely
starts Frankie Edgar that nobody wanted
to cheer for that has to be one of the
only Knockouts where nobody was cheering
in master Square Garden and the crowd
even after he got knocked out people
chanting Frankie Frankie so for Chris
Gutierrez
tough tough uh night in the office
meaning no matter what you do unless you
get knocked out people aren't going to
root for you nobody's rooting for Chris
Gutierrez except for his family in the
front row outside that every single
person probably even in his hometown was
rooting for Frankie Edgar the legend his
send-off fight how dare you his send-off
fight you're gonna knee that man in the
face and Flatline him
do you know how disrespect his send-off
fight here's the thing though
no matter who your favorite fighter is
Frankie Edgar PJ Penn Chuck Liddell shot
Evans we can keep going through the list
whoever it is uh Sanchez
whoever it is if they stick around long
enough
they end up face down ass up
or
head down ass down this flat line you
know just on their back so that that's
the way this that's the way the game
goes if you stick around long enough
this is gonna happen it's just the way
it is
also with the UFC I'm not did you have
to give him Chris Gutierrez
on a send-off thing who have not have
done like a a Dominic Cruz Frankie Edgar
like a Legends fight because we've
showed him a little more respect Mass
Square Garden his last fight you give
him this long you know Savage young line
with dangerous knees for Frankie Edgar
the funniest is Chris Gutierrez you
could tell he's crying big moment for
huge fight in his career like forget
whatever the naysayers and the Frank
Yeager fans like you did your job
biggest win in your career
then he goes to pick Frankie I'm
thinking no no no stop stop this this
isn't this isn't a good moment for me
don't pick me up even though it's my
last fight don't pick me up and prayed
me around the ring this is not what we
had planned I plan to beat the [ __ ] out
of you it's Frankie Edgar Legend man
forget your first guest ever on food
truck Diaries went and ate that New
Jersey pizza and it was fantastic I Love
Frankie salt of the earth great dad
great family dude just a legend he did
have a Frank Edgar UFC Gym out there in
New Jersey that is part of I wonder if
that's are the UFC Gym still popping
yeah they're still doing the thing yeah
I feel like it's died down a little bit
right well I guess pandemic kind of shut
those down but
if it's fun by the UFC they're fine yeah
you'll see fit right here because I know
it's a UFC gym but it's different
because also like see how it says
Frankie Edgar yeah most of them don't
say that like BJ Penn Hawaii that's his
big gym I think there's two of them I
think Bisping has one Orange County I
want to say
no I say hasm I mean the UFC builds when
they just tosses her name out and they
get some sort of ownership let's say
it's like 10 it should be way more than
that but
what can you do
I see what you did there today she looks
jacked yep so I heard rumors are from
Adrian Yanez uh that Frankie kind of
wanted that fight which sounds kind of
crazy like he actually chose that guy
but there's rumors yeah it makes sense
it's Frankie Edgar dude you're talking
about a legend of course you want that
no no Frankie chose him that's what I'm
saying but his team and his his team and
his coaching go bro yeah yeah he can
probably beat that guy hey man let's
have a fun night this is a celebration
of your career let's go out there let's
leave on a good foot and you know no
head trauma get out of there let's fight
a wrestler who's just gonna try to take
you down you light him up let's get off
on a good note why would you fight some
young lion Christian Terrace man it was
a bummer yeah that that was that was
such a bummer to me now if hooker would
have lost before and then gutera and
then Frankie gets killed like that I
shut this thing off
uh and then the fire the night probably
as of now probably fight of the year
and it's tough to live up to the hype
because remember I had to watch this on
Sunday and again uh 5 a.m this morning
when my kid wakes me up he's like Daddy
I don't watch whatever uh Pepe the pig
I'm like you're gonna watch UFC 281
enjoy this buddy you enjoy all the blood
and Dustin Perry Michael Chandler fight
but so many people were texting me dude
round of the Year fight of the Year oh
my this fight this fight so I have
already this High preconceived notion oh
this can be crazy it's very rare it
lives up to the hype my God this fight
was fantastic Dustin Poirier Michael
Chandler two my boys didn't give you
guys a pick uh on this fight for that
reason I'm too close both of them I love
both of them I hate that they had to
fight each other Michael Chandler has to
be the best lightweight of all time in
the first round to ever exist I don't
care who you are if you don't have a
granite chin nobody is making out of
that first round Michael Chandler his
first rounds are in Fuego he literally
has to be the best 155er to ever do it
in five minutes but you better survive
it because he you know you're looking at
some 10-8 rounds those first rounds but
if they survive he slows down and I
couldn't believe Dustin poor at his age
he's been fighting New Seasons he was
like eight he was like 3 000 fights in
the UFC figured that you know you can't
take the same shots my god dude the
shots he was taken from Michael Chandler
bro and then Chandler slamming them
riding his ass I was a good man
Chandler's dominating him even the
second round I mean Dustin Lance some
good shots that second round was gang
busters
you know so for
Michael Chandler when you look at this
and I said this to to Brian
um when we were breaking down and
finding the kid I said you know Dustin
Poirier will fancy himself
um a gunslinger and when he if you do
that against Chandler it's tough because
Chandler does hit harder
but the one thing that I didn't
emphasize enough on is I set the support
he's a better Striker as far as
technique-wise he his shots are straight
Mike challenge he's a loop loopy guy
he's a loopy Punch guy uppercut guy
right but there's a lot more power there
the issue is is when you get in those
exchanges when you get in those phone
booth exchanges the guy who's the crispr
more technical Striker can win those so
it doesn't probably hit hard I say you
know Chandler if this is a video game
challenge probably a 10 out of 10 or 9
out of 10. Depends at 55. Now France is
a 10 out of 10. you know I'm not
comparing to Francona at 55 challenge
probably a 10 out of 10 with his
explosive athleticism power does support
he's probably eight and a half not too
far off the difference is his poor a
throw straight punches so when they get
in those wild exchanges although
Chandler's Landing some poor a because
of his precision and his technique was
getting the upper hand on those
exchanges even know he's getting lit up
I'm not talking about the first round
the second round where they're really
trading back and forth if you notice
Chandler was Landing poire was Landing
before his shots counted more because
they were more precise they're in better
spots and that's where Chandler was
getting in trouble man he's in a lot of
trouble
and then when he was you know he's out
wrestling I love Chandler's wrestling I
wish he would do it more
but what's interesting about Chandler is
when he does decide to engage in the
grappling that's when he gets in the
most trouble so you know you probably
have
I don't know if you want to go 10-8 you
know in that first round and pour a it's
close but I don't know what the official
judge's scorecards is we can link it up
to him if you look that up but I some
people would probably have Chandler on
top especially we gave him one of those
rounds 10-8 so that third round he's
going to win in that fight
and then you know challenge doesn't have
it in a man he doesn't have an him go
I'm up on the scorecards let's chill out
let's put take the foot off the gas
let's you got this dude let's be more
precise and here we go
they never give teddies these [ __ ]
people so it was 1919 going to that
third round so it's straight even
um you know I'm more a fan of of 10 8
rounds especially when there's complete
domination like that I'd go first round
ten eight second round okay yeah Knight
ten boy had him really really hurt
wobble was laying more precise shots
I'm cool with this there's no issue here
so it's all tied up going into that
third round
um so yeah so Chandler really didn't
have the opportunity to take the foot
off the the gas there
but I think being three rounds too he
goes so goddamn hard in the paint you
know it's tough for him and then then
when he wants to get these takedowns
takedowns look phenomenal you slam them
doing all this [ __ ]
then he's a he's a step behind you know
he's always a step behind and when
Chandler uh which was beautiful this
shows his black belt the way he was able
to get his neck if he knows and it was
originally when he when he took him down
to take his back and sink in a joke
originally it was it was more of a chin
it was more it's more on the chin but
Chandler I'm sorry uh poor a new in the
transition with the blood it was gonna
slip under then he got the submission
phenomenal fight
phenomenal [ __ ] fight just some boys
talk just keeps going and going which I
love to see with these veterans just
keeps going going up I would assume
Justin poor is looking at a
if he wants to fight soon which I don't
think he does he's a family guy likes to
chill and he only wants really big
fights but if he's looking to get back
at the title I would assume he'd have to
get through Darius if he wants to fight
again in the next you know first quarter
second quarter looking at a derus fight
um or you know I'm curious of UFC
because Dustin is such a big name what
happens with the mock Chev and
volkanovski five Mark Jeff wins that
right he looks Unstoppable and they want
to get another big name under uh Michael
chebs kind of resume you give him Dustin
pore that would really solidify him at
55 doesn't support he's been a you know
a face of that division for how long
fighting the top of the top was a world
champion he's beat Conor McGregor so I
think that would go a long way for Mark
ches record I can see the UFC doing that
and especially Dustin likes to chill you
know he likes to rest and recover
especially after a fight like that
definitely there's definitely some
concoction going on there so if I'm
Dustin I don't rush back especially to
fight a guy in Darius unfortunately for
dare use he's number four guy in the
world but he's the least famous in the
top [ __ ] five
there's gang bangers in the top five
gang bangers these guys are First Team
all nasty you got mock Jeff Superstar
Charles Olivera Superstar doesn't pour
the diamond Superstar great hot sauce
great bourbon he got Justin gaichi
Superstar Michael Chandler Superstar
four
that's your top five six include the
champion Mark Chev so he's the least
famous least amount of followers which
this is I want to kick myself in the
nuts when I talk like this but that's
the UFC's game plan right they they go
for these big fights and sometimes you
get you know what's right in the
rankings but it's very rare these days
you know it's kind of you know what's
your Twitch following like what everyone
nine in a run I know but your Instagram
followers under 100 000 we're so sorry
go and fight nine more Savages and also
is it do you think you could dance on
Tick Tock for us could you do that
Darius I know could you do like a Jesus
dance for us on Tick Tock every Tuesday
say I don't think so like okay we're
gonna have you fight somebody outside
the top ten then it's not fun it's not
fair Dairy deserves it and Darius pore
is a hell of a fight
uh
I would assume Corey might be a dog or
maybe a slight dog in that fight
to be honest with you there's just
Savage on the ground has you know he
he's kind of like Dustin Poirier when
the shots are flying you want him you
know to be your guy he has all the power
we'll bite down on his freaking
mouthpiece and again that phone booth
fight and he's very precise at it too so
it's Poirier that's a great [ __ ]
fight so for Porey though is that going
to get you away from the family is that
going to get you away from promoting the
hot sauce he just dropped a new one dude
also we got I gotta hit him up to get it
here for food truck I always ask for hot
sauce we're just using random hot sauce
uh his bourbon's fantastic so he's a
businessman outside and he's doing his
thing this is when you build his profile
more so for Poirier the UFC goes all
right Darius and I don't know March I
don't think it's party out of bed
remember even Chandler didn't really get
poorie out of back because boy he's like
I'm looking for a big fight maybe Nate
Diaz which Nate Diaz probably would be a
fantastic fight but that's not happening
is it so for poor it's Portia it's
either
weight if the UFC even is handing out
this which I would assume they would for
many of reasons for mock Jeff
uh winner over you know volcanovski
fight and to fight for the title you
know or you look what what else is out
there you know I don't know I don't know
but they're in a tough spot and then uh
on the latter end of that the guy who's
on the losing end Michael Chandler
he's was he two and four in the UFC now
or I'm sorry yeah right two two and
three let's see
so he has won one fight so he's two and
three so he's two and three
he's lost three of his last four
but but
that so the Dan hooker fight performs
the night starches Dan hooker right
that's a good win Charles Olivera 10-8
first round and then again second round
gets in some trouble Justin gaichi five
of the year
performance like it's reward Tony
Ferguson
knockout of the year right complete
insane Spartan 300 kick to the [ __ ]
face of Tony Ferguson performance of the
night every single fight he's had in the
UFC's got a Bonus every single fight
always great he's great but if you're
Chandler at the end of the day so right
now currently we all love Michael
Chandler I love Michael Chandler one of
my favorite people one of my favorite
humans to fight inside that steel cage
in his underwear those uh spandex they
rocked with that blowout ass I'm a fan
of a great person great dad great
fighter in five years though we're gonna
forget this stuff and then you look at
his resume it's wins and losses all the
UFC cares about is wins and loss at the
end of the day now he's not an
interpretive getting cut not can happen
he puts on a show but then in the day
for Chandler he wants to be world
champion the only reason he's fighting
it's not to put on exciting first rounds
and lose down the line that's not why
he's doing this so
he has to kind of go back to the drawing
board his team well and just go all
right man that first round they're great
and you're winning you you know you've
won every first round you've had but
we're not not we're not getting the end
result that we need so we gotta maybe
pull back in that first round still win
but don't don't blow your nut on that
first round it's not working for us so
for channel he drops back in the queue
and that queue is freaking stacked you
know and there's a lot of other guys a
lot of other matchups so
you know you he he definitely win his
next one you know it's about wins and
losses not not just being exciting you
don't want to be the Leonard Garcia the
UFC it's a tough gig man tough tough gig
you want to be that guy like yeah I know
he doesn't win but so much fun to watch
you got kids and then also depend how
much UFC pays you don't get twisted DLC
is like yeah great great fight dude but
when you're losing they will hold that
over your head all freaking day even
though the fan base like no this is
great I'm telling the UFC if they have
any chips in the corner they're gonna be
like well no dude he's only won two UFC
fights out of five you and he wants to
pay him how much it's not happening you
know so it gets a little dicey for him
there he gets a little dice for him I
absolutely love him I think he beats
most guys it's just the tip of the spare
guys he's struggling with because they
they're they're not they're no punks
that first round even though it didn't
go those guys ways there's a reason
they're so successful they're not
they're they can throw interception and
forget about it and still perform so he
beats everybody but just not the tip of
the spirit guys right now but I think
with a few minor tweaks he's right there
man he's right there he's right there
let's take a little break about me just
chatting your ear off about physical
it's never too early to play holiday
music we already got the Christmas tree
up in my house I like to do it after
Thanksgiving but my Mexican wife begs it
different for the kids it can't come
early enough it's never too early to
start thinking about gifts either
whether it's for a friend or your
friends in your pants you can make this
season to be jolly with my boys at
manscaped do your little drummer boy a
favorite and use the lawnmower 4.0 to
avoid other Silent Night in the bedroom
all right then add in manscape's top of
the line shower products to have people
thinking All I Want For Christmas Is You
Baby Santa cares about his sack and so
should you look nice when you get
naughty and get free shipping with 20
off by going to manscape.com shop
Schaub the manscape Platinum package 4.0
is a One-Stop shop for the Bro who
deserves it all give your man something
that just keeps on giving if he has a
bush and because he's scared he doesn't
want to Nick his nuts you're not bleed
like crazy he's sick of it so he just
strolls around with this heavy Bush
don't don't do that don't let him go out
there and be scared because listen
manscape is here with the Platinum
package they got it all to get the Ultra
Premium body wash Ultra Premium two in
one shampoo conditioner Ultra Premium
deodorant all right the lawnmower 4.0
body trimmer weed whacker nose air air
trimmer we got you man I also have a
light on it and it's waterproof you can
do it in the shower it's super easy they
got the crop preserver ball deodorant
crop reviver ball toner can solve stank
problems all freaking day long all right
the Platinum 4.0 packets and on your
tree is guaranteed to put anyone in the
holiday spirit get that big tasty sack
like Santa all right for the perfect
stocking stuffer adding the brand new
body buffer incredible body scrubber
that makes it easy to foliate all your
body man get that body right get to
himself and free shipping at
manscape.com shop schab that's 20 off
for free shipping at manscape.com
manscape get your jingle balls ready for
the holidays ho ho ho
it's the holidays man and you got a lot
of work on your table you got friends
and family coming over and you're like
man I shouldn't get this project or this
assignment done whatever you're working
on I need to be in the zone I'm gonna be
in that flow State how can I get there
I've tried meditation I've tried it all
I've kind of looked into nootropics but
I don't know what to take well take from
your fake friend here there's only one
nootropic your boy uses here in ABCD I
use Alpha Brain from on it's the only
nootropic I trust they go through so
many trials make sure it is the best on
the market all right they sold over 1
million bottles that's right one million
bottles Alpha Brain promotes cognitive
function include memory mental speed and
focus helps you remember names at these
Christmas parties little Alpha Brain
next you know your eat basically Elon
Musk without the autism we got you
covered man all right comedian and
podcaster my boy Joe Rogan says it makes
him feel like you inform better
sentences when he's talking you want to
talk more like Rogan come on man we got
you guys also
on it so positive you're going to love
uh Alpha Brain that you get your money
back guaranteed if you don't like it no
return necessary keep the bottle give it
to your buddies all right they're not as
big as haters it's gonna work so don't
even worry about it all right and also
it's caffeine free so if you're you know
generated caffeine don't worry about it
I'll bring caffeine free now you can
pick it up at your local Walmart or you
can do what most people do and go to
audit.com shop Schaub you attempt to
knock the entire website not just Alpha
Brain but but protein powder Warrior
bars workout gear battle ropes
kettlebells we got it all honor.com shop
temps off the entire site especially
Alpha Brain you're welcome now let's get
back to the program
um the moving on your co-main event
you know probably the most boring fight
on the card you know it's such a
mismatch it was a complete nightmare for
Carlos sparza this wasn't surprising I
guess the surprising thing there is how
good uh way is that grappling and
wrestling because when she came in on
the UFC she was an absolute monster and
with her stand up and we knew her to be
this knockout artist unless she was
fighting uh Thug Rose but uh you know so
you can see the Improvement in waylay it
seems like waylay might be you know go
on a streak here it should be tough to
beat now she's more comfortable with her
grappling with Carla Esparza you know
getting that single legging again lit up
and then to get you know submitted the
way she did wayley looked pretty damn
good couldn't be a worse matchup for
Carlos Esparza especially since waylay
learned how to wrestle and do grappling
couldn't be an absolute nightmare for
Carlos sparza so her Carlos sparza's
journey and story still fantastic you
think what she won Ultimate five maybe
seven eight years ago she was champ lost
the belt became champ again it's a great
comeback story but that Carlos Barnes
the train stops in China she's never
gonna beat Whaley it's just not going to
happen uh for for Rose she's the
Achilles heel to weighing now that she
has this [ __ ] grapple though it could
be a little difference there I would
like some fresh blood in there
at straw weight we've had the same
basically handful of women you know
running this thing you got waylay you
got Rose young gen check and then you've
got
um Carlos barza and it just gone Josh
you kind of get the same girls there so
uh Lemos I'd love to see her get a crack
at it
um depending what Rose wants to do rose
doesn't seem like she's jumping the bit
to get in that I thought Marina
Rodriguez for you to beat uh limo she'd
been right there but
Amanda limos should fight for the time
just to switch it up man I like when
there's a little bit of you know
be more interesting we've seen Rose
we've seen
um you know Jessica and Josh we've seen
some of these girls so
I think Lemos is the pick there I bet
you if he does that and I bet Rose she's
just again it's not like she's chomping
at the bits we'll see what happens there
and then your main event
your main event you know I told y'all
you must have forgot and as he was
proving me right until about three
minutes into that fifth round you know
uh that was the end of the first is he
rocked them it's so crazy to me how this
pretty much duplicated the last
kickboxing kickboxing match between
these two gentlemen it was almost
identical because if you've seen those
fights his he's winning lighting him up
and then you know Pierre just has so
much power to catch him in the fights
over that's so much power that guy has
um I thought Izzy looked phenomenal I
thought uh is he doing a good job with
the light kicks like he did mention the
post fight uh press conference he did
throw a leg kick and uh Alex checked it
and then it messed up whatever the nerve
is in his leg so he felt compromised
there he was like after that it's kind
of trouble for me which makes sense but
that's also it's not like
you know
Alex threw the kick and intentionally
did it but what Alex did was check it
which is you know a combat fight move
and he did the right thing and that
compromised Izzy so kudos to Alex Pierre
um
I I still believe that Izzy's the better
fighter I think for Izzy
you know he's been so dominant and
people kind of get sick of that
especially when you think he's not you
know fighting like he used to we always
hear this from he's not fine like you
used to now he's this he's a boring
Champion but I couldn't disagree more
with that I think it's more
um
credit to Izzy the way he's fighting and
I think it's more of a product of his
opponents not bringing the fight because
he's so goddamn good
um so the UFC knew that they need a
spark of fire under Izzy's ass because
he's just dominating everybody there's
no fresh blood for him so their Hope was
Alex Pierre would be the guy who's the
Achilles heel of Izzy and seems to be
that way right he's 3-0 against Izzy two
in kickboxing now an MMA
um
you know but again Izzy's definitely one
more rounds over Alex but he's just not
winning the fights so
you know again and also Dennis said this
Izzy's one of the only Champions he has
he's just you want to stay active and he
had no reservation about fighting
octopia even though he's flatlined him
before he's like you have to sign him up
let's do it and I thought Izzy was the
better more technical Striker Alex
Pierre I thought he was a little
reserved especially in the first three
rounds because
he's never gone 25 minutes so he would
close distance and how is he going
backwards but he wouldn't do a lot with
it I thought his leg kicks um were great
super high level I thought his body
um punches and kicks were great shows
what level he's at he's an absolute
Savage and also just his size Advantage
my God I tell you guys how big his he is
and let me see Alex and they're like oh
this looks organic Izzy version like he
was he's Alex should fight at 205 I
don't know if he wants to but Alex
Pierre and
um year he'd be a great fight
I don't know who'd win that fight that's
how experience dude is a Savage
um but I again I'm not taking anything
from Alex I just feel like and this is
what shows you what true champion is he
is he could have coasted that fifth
round he could coach that fifth round
won this fight easily I think every
judge had is he up on the cards four to
zero eight three to one three one three
it was a three to one yeah three to one
I mean that first round could do 10-8
there's 30 more seconds the fight's over
that thing's over he was on freaking
Sixth Street you know wobbling his legs
and the punch came after the Bell but
the motion was going when the bell rang
so that wasn't dirty to me but I thought
as he started finding his timing there
the compromisation of the leg
um you know Izzy in the rematch is
slightly favored which makes sense to me
I would agree with that but Alex Pierre
just hit so hard I'd have a problem with
the stoppage even as he was like maybe a
little early stoppage but I don't have
any issue with it you know
um so
you know I I do think um
is in Oxford they're a great matchup
they're definitely gonna do the rematch
you have to is he you know he's won 12
in a row he's defend his bill up five
times now so couldn't break uh Anderson
Silva's record which shows you how
[ __ ] great answer and Silva is who
just got beat by Jake Paul that's a
different story
um not an MMA but you know what I'm
saying it's insane how you don't realize
some of these records till you freaking
these guys attempt to do it like what
Izzy's attempt to do is insane dude so
shout out to spider there but
you know I I think for
Izzy he's gonna go back and watch that
fine bike is similar to the first fight
but similar to second fight like I'm out
classroom line them up you know could
have had some finishes there if I would
have put the pressure on a little more
um but you let Alex hang around with
that power and if he eventually you know
decides to go when he goes you better be
out of the way or you can lose the fight
you know you're just gonna lose the
fight so I also credit both of them
because
whenever you have two guys are this high
level at striking this makes martial
arts usually one guy will you know and
they did do some grappling but as far as
the Striking goes they're usually both a
little reserved so we don't get a great
kind of
um result when it comes to striking game
they're a little hesitant but these guys
showed out it just shows you how [ __ ]
good they are
um
again I'm not taking anything away from
Alex but again I don't think he beats a
single guy in the top five
um Robert Whittaker's after he saw Izzy
and Alex's grappling in the wrestling
you know I'm sure every guy in top five
is like dear God please give me that guy
because for those guys that can actually
wrestle and they actually you know have
not just one takedown but they have an
Arsenal they have chain wrestling and
they have Jiu Jitsu higher than a blue
belt they're foaming at the dick to get
their hands on oxy pier and UFC knows
this and they're gonna protect him like
hamzat tweeted out was like oh offline
at 85 I'll be your champ now if the UFC
actually won Hamza to be that big of a
superstar at 70 n85 your next fight to
me harms up for Sox Pierre
Hamza beats the [ __ ] out he mops the
floor you know again I'm not taking
anything from Alex this is all about
matchups and styles and that's a
complete nightmare for him the UFC is
not going to do that because then it
discredits
is he's kind of entire resume right
because then
if Izzy never gets that
fourth fight really the the second fight
MMA which all we care about but if he
never gets that rematch against Alex
and then Alex fights anybody else and
loses and never gets because they have
to have him fight Izzy otherwise you'll
never hear him from him again I gotta be
honest so the UFC knows that and it'd
also be a huge kind of
Mark against Izzy in his career if he
couldn't redeem himself and get a win
over Alex it's like yo you know because
if let's say Robert Whittaker beat
um Alex which I think you would let's
say Jared Cannon air Marvin Victoria or
Derek Brunson or Paulo Costa Jack
Hermanson any of these guys beat him
izzies and beat those guys and he's
proved it he'll destroy all those guys
but there's that one that demon out
there Alex Pierre that Brazilian demon
who's just gonna get past so if he's not
allowed to happen you're not gonna see
him fight anybody else this is a
straight Izzy thing for it makes Izzy
more exciting right this comeback story
he is slightly favored which I agree
with because he's the rounds that he's
won over Alex so he just needs to fight
smarter
um the the problem is though is oxpeare
also can get footage of that last fight
so action watch and go oh I know I can I
know I have power for 25 minutes I know
I can push myself a little further that
was my first 25 minute fight ever so
he's gonna be a little more less gun shy
in this rematch which is a problem for
Izzy you know now it could just be a
thing where ask me here is just for
whatever reason stylistically is the
only guy on this planet that can be
dizzy
I'm not talking about 205 I'm not I'm
just talking about 185. 85 asked period
could just be that one Thorn and Izzy
side they just can't get past for
whatever reason he does well you know
for so long and then there's some mental
block where you know you take your eye
off that off the prize and
Pierre has so much knockout Powers he's
gonna shut your lights out so
um it is a it's a good story for Alex
Pierre you know it's a great story when
they were grappling I was like please
stop please please stop I did not pay on
a Sunday night and known the results
eighty dollars to watch these two
white and blue belt grapple let's get
back on the feet and get to business
here you know what I'm saying look
please don't grab it's like when uh was
it Damian Ben asked from striking I was
like well I want to cut my dick off this
is I'd rather watch my two-year-old and
five-year-old fight each other they have
better technique at stand up this is all
give me my Goddamn money back but for uh
pure and Izzy man hats off to him and
also it just shows you the true champ
that is he is the way he dealt with the
loss you know if you listen to his
comment on post fight and he's in that
dope ass fur Coke that's what a champion
looks like son that's what he looks like
he evolved credit to Alex and he said
yeah we'll run it back it's all good so
I I think for for Izzy this is actually
a good thing because I think frizzy's
been so dominant it's been kind of
lackluster this brings him to the to the
Forefront people get to see what he's
really about you know
mm-hmm
what's up I'm just reading some of these
Bros about to visit God if the ref came
a couple more seconds that's what most
people want to see though I thought it
was early but sometime reflect on it I
think it's better than the way it did
than to possibly have Izzy Flat Line
completely turned into meme sleeping on
the beach by the Z haters yeah you know
I think for Izzy to go out like this
there's really no argument it wasn't so
bad where people are going to constantly
make fun of them right it's not like a a
Dan Henderson Bisping moment
um it's not like a Luke rockhold vitro
Belfor spinning back kick moment dude
Alex Pierre I don't know if people
notice this but as Peter threw a
spinning heel kick and it was like uh it
was like a cressing like spinning heel
kick and Izzy like turned down but if
that thing was just an inch further my
God you got knocked out of the year that
would have been awful awful off of
you're an Izzy fan which I am so I bet
they do the rematch if I'm Izzy I chill
for a little bit and do the rematching
thank you very much April April April
may take a little time off April May now
I don't know if the division is going to
put up with that but that's what I would
do take your rest
enjoy life get back to business you know
you're better than this guy you just
gotta fight smarter I truly believe
because he's been in this guy I believe
that wholeheartedly now your boy's out
five grand right I sent count on the
cash app Saturday night without even
watching the fight I saw a win right so
Alex wants to count I knew and I knew he
won because before even the fans at the
Houston Improv during the meet greets
told me what happened which I knew was
they were going to tell me so
um I hear a text from all I got from
Brian goes pay up I was like ah damn
I was like first round second round he's
like no as he was doing well in that
fifth round like [ __ ] I did not predict
the late round knockout just didn't see
that happening but I do think you almost
forgot how goddamn good his he is you
know hope he's reminded you a little bit
even though he lost that should remind
you how [ __ ] dominant of champion is
he is I think this prayer forgets his
career I think it adds more fuel to the
fire I think it gives brings more fans
to him now that the champ lost we're
going to see a champ come back and trust
me as he's going to come back I would
double I'm when we do find a kid after
this I'll double the bet with brown 10
G's
double nothing what happens if he wins
that uh rematch they do it again no no
no that's it that's it that's it is he
loses him a second time then again I
think that's it for both of these guys
yeah this is for if our spirit it'd be a
nightmare for the division kind of but
if our spirit would beat Izzy again it's
just the thorn and Izzy side Izzy has to
Hope Alex either goes up to 205 or you
know they do toss him a Grappler and he
can get Molly [ __ ] then as he can get
back to the belt because he beats
everybody not named Alex Pierre hands
down everybody
um you know obviously I think you know
bow nickel coming up the
it's tough dude you got Bo nickel coming
up through the ranks even though I don't
have a fight once they come up to the
ranks definitely get a fight by nickel
and then you know you got hamzat in the
in the waiting in the the [ __ ]
chechny or whatever the hell he is
Shadows you know so it's like there's a
time period for both these gentlemen do
work right now because those boys are
coming those boys coming and the big
what I think probably the one of the
biggest fights ever happens to me Bo
nickel and hom thought that's the fight
that's the fight yeah
so overall dude Massacre Garden
delivered and that's an understatement
it's just it's just a special place
people show out man people absolutely
show out so
um great card man great card absolutely
great card
what do you got Jen
starting off with sad news you already
know this for that Anthony Rumble
Johnson passed away at 38 years old yeah
and I think people
um in history even if you're a circle
not in the media but if you're in a
circle you know me and Rumble would
attacks back and forth DM back and forth
um I knew he wasn't doing well I didn't
know it was this bad I knew it was bad
um then even his manager all he came out
was okay pray for for
um Rumble men he's not doing he could
use pressure and they're like oh this
can't be good you know just such a shame
was he 38 38 he was 38. this is a post
he did in September I really wish I'd go
into detail about how ill I truly am
just uh no I need as many prayers as I
can get and I'll see you in 2022 God
willing to have been this afraid of
anything my um that makes sense but I've
remained strong with the support my
friend the family that's terrible that's
terrible 38 man 38 38 and putting
capital letters not covets all you
people like God best go in vaccines
you're completely [ __ ] off you guys
couldn't be more off stop with that [ __ ]
oh was it steroids no it's not steroids
what he was dealing with a hot Hodgkin's
lymphomia you know and
hemophagic or some [ __ ] those for sure
science make it short uh lymphosis I
know the rear disorder of the immune
system what he told me
because we're talking about food truck
he's like dude I gotta go check in the
hospital what he told me is at the white
blood cells were like attacking
someone's body like and the goods the
healthy stuff they're just turned like
his bodies turned on like it was like
the white blood cells were doing
something moves there I forget what it
was if they attacked them or there's too
much in his body it wasn't good
it wasn't good or maybe it was the red
blood cells attacking the white blood
cells he was so low on white blood cells
was like super dangerous for him
um is a rare but potential fatal
condition with certain white blood cells
build up in damage or there you go uh so
the condition that he had is uh certain
white blood cells build up and build up
and damage organs including the bone
marrow liver spleen and Destroy other
blood cells
dude how about that commonly affects
infants and young children super rare
it's so nuts dude go to what's the
survival rate of it right there see that
if left untreated patients with this
disease survive only few months wow due
to organ failing that's what got Rumble
man
oh wow so with dragon increased the
survival rate to you basically have a 50
chance of surviving up
was six years oh Jesus what a terrible
Condition it's just so he's so young man
it's just such a [ __ ] shame just a
great guy too yeah he was on food truck
and he came into Grudge Training Center
when he was first popping on the scene
at 170 and my God the talent that dude
possessed was nachos Southpaw
traditional you're just a interesting
thing like it and that and I remember
looking he's like 220 some pounds like
you fight at 170. this is nuts dude
remember he fought in uh what was that
World Series knocked out or he went to I
think decision or lavski like the guy is
a Savage man his fights with DC
it's just such a shame man it's such a
freaking shame yeah super such a bummer
um all right looking back to the fights
I thought this was really cool let me go
here this is Dustin Porter talking to
Michael Chandler after the fight post
fight
[Music]
so he admitted that he was scared to
fight himself because remember they know
each other from ATT he knows the power
of Chandler I heard about their you know
sparring sessions at ATT like I'm sure
for for uh Porey that especially when
you know the guy now James is what he's
really good at like now that stuff eats
up at you before the fight like ah that
one time we're training he got me in the
compromised position and he landed that
shot so all that's going through your
head man boy he's just such a dog I know
my god dude
and then um so I guess remember you were
talking about how uh channel one for the
choke yeah with the fish hook yeah
that's so uh Chandler said that it was
like it didn't mean to do it obviously
he's not a cheat or anything like
anything anything like that but he did
accidentally put his hands in there yeah
and then I guess Dustin Porter did like
kind of bite down hell yeah I mean all
fears in 11 more I mean obviously you
shouldn't be doing that but uh and then
this part too so Chandler I guess his
nose is all clogged up with blood and
then they're wondering people wondering
if he did this on purpose like SP you
know blue it's not rocket onto for you
but she said no there was just something
that had to come out so I'll just show
you these two don't get monkey pox I
don't know what's gonna do it Hotel oh
that's so nice oh no I don't think he
meant to do that he didn't he's
literally he's you know my nose right
now right now to keep it keep it uh keep
it stopping from bleeding I mean it was
if I wanted to breathe
that blood needed to come out
um so I mean it wasn't a it wasn't a
malicious weird thing but it was
definitely like hey man sorry you're
down there but I didn't I didn't create
gravity
I didn't create gravity you all winking
at him I didn't
thank you thank you
he looks so different yeah I mean his
face is super swollen
great dude right yeah great yeah
um oh yeah we did the Petrosky one so
Jim Norton got this footage from Bax uh
backstage
and it's Kevin Holland and Kevin Hollins
I guess
arguing with someone from our usman's
team I can't tell who it is but then he
calls him an actor so maybe someone from
the wakanda forever movie interesting
so there's Eastman and the Kevin Hans
are you
Hill
Ary
hey bro you're the actor not me
Jamal Hill is there too I don't think I
was saying I don't know what happened
building altercation but I say it's not
sure what the issue was almost lost my
phone
luckily Reed Harris who's the best read
that [ __ ] the amount of [ __ ] readers
let's deal with in that UFC he if he
wrote a tell-all book he can't but I
sent an NDA but my God
hey everyone talks really good about
Reed
uh yeah so no idea what happened try to
Google it can't find out what happened
um this is another altercation with Nate
Diaz and Dylan Dennis's team and someone
put down that Dylan Dennis got slapped
by nadius but it was one of Dylan's no
someone else yeah the only guy close
enough to do it but it was a it was a
bad slap maybe slapping like a penguin
man you just be slapping
I think he manages Dylan and then he's
also Connors
what is Ollie trying to tell him
kids are here so don't cause any trouble
or something like that he's like my kids
are here man be cool
he slapped the piss at him
this guy was small but I don't get what
he is talking [ __ ] to Nate and then also
if you can talk [ __ ] them you know he
slaps dude I know that's such an
embarrassing thing to get caught on
camera with getting slapped nothing
worse yeah
I'd rather Nate punch when he gets like
there's nothing more than getting
slapped and the guy just an open hand
slap but I was that short guy talking
[ __ ] to him what do you what are you
doing it's humiliating yeah
uh all right so we talked about Dominic
Reyes this is uh Jon Jones talking about
Dominic Reyes like he's he's like going
back and forth with fans on his Twitter
so I'll tell you he's confident in his
mind he beat me maybe that's his problem
so someone asked it's crazy how much
Johnny Bones took Reyes his confidence
and then this guy goes do you feel bad
for Dom I don't feel bad I don't know if
I feel bad or the words I would say more
like concern for his health yeah I'm
with you John and then got on the
thoughts probably or get in the game so
that's something that Dominic Reyes said
a few days before by Jon Jones so then
Jon Jones put that out there
it was as much to be honest last series
now that's my message back to him oh wow
yeah you go up what was the get it get
it get on the sidelines permanently or
get in the game yeah like stay out on
Sidelines or just you know because Jon
Jones is Not really no I know and then
Danos came out was like Stephen John was
never gonna happen in December wow he's
like that I don't know where that came
from
damn
I know for a fact it was supposed to
happen yeah but Dana said that uh and
this is Dominic reyes's hold on oh
there's an old interview here's dump
Donna Grace's statement I was trying to
get my hand raised and rest the fight
I'm okay I love to fight another day
another lesson learned congrats one
incredible performance become the
middleweight champion
oh God is always good congrats back to
be here we know that channel guys always
good I think my first family support me
on management
a big thank you to to Glover's team for
the camp believe me I'll be back just
have to shake it off and get back in
there big thing to UFC energy was
amazing last night it felt great to be
in the rain again yeah he just needs to
be more active he's had some tough goes
man yeah since that John fight's been
[ __ ] tough for this guy
heavyweight is just not forgiven man
it's also tough yeah it's my secret
Grant your first fight back in a hot
second you know
and now he hasn't won since 2019. it's
tough man that was a really hard job
when you looked at it yeah his momentum
come forward your people you're knocked
up by jab it's like dude that ain't got
regular Street basing overhand left Jake
Paul he teased this thing just a little
video footage of him put it on Twitter
your boy's more active on Twitter now
that Elon took it over yeah I'm not
being suppressed I came on every other
channel
but that's them squaring I don't know I
wonder if that's real now this is my
thing with this for Jake it makes sense
I mean for you know Andrew Tate
definitely makes sense because he's not
really doing these fights like this but
uh for Jake you got to be careful I know
Logan Paul called him out but I think
Logan Paul like tore every ligament in
his knee recently so he's out for a hot
second
for Jake though don't don't get twisted
I know you know Andrew Tate a lot of you
know especially the young listeners know
him as that misogynist or whatever your
parents told you that this guy is and he
got kicked off all this stuff you got to
realize his background he is a legit
world champion kickboxer
legit you know he's not that old be a
tough fight for Jake if I'm educated he
should probably take it you know yeah
yeah I mean they're both popular enough
to make this a big uh I'll be a huge
yeah also I told you guys this if I'm
Jake dude forget being validated by the
MMA community and boxing me [ __ ]
everybody dude because your toughest
fight against Andrew Silva It's your
lowest pay-per-view numbers now maybe it
was because Anderson before the you know
in the press conference said he got
knocked out to be like oh God to see me
a good fight so maybe that hurt it but
still your toughest fight was your
lowest pay for your numbers read the
room buddy fight guys I can't rotate now
it's not easy by any means that's tough
fight for Jake but keep fighting these
guys why why what are you aiming for
yeah nothing proved to any of us keep
doing your thing make all the money in
the world because we fight your toughest
tasks lowest views
yeah it's kind of crazy the pudding my
man [ __ ] validation just keep making
40 million dollars a year and tell
people to suck your weiner
living in Costa Rica where the hell he's
at Puerto Rico I think but yeah
I don't know he does it okay so some
bout announcements you already know this
is happening but it's official now so
Alexander volkanovsky I know because
there was rumors that it didn't look
like it was going to happen because
online too it was getting a little dicey
but now I'll tell you what the the
kangaroo nuts that Al volkanovsky has to
step in that octagon with
in Perth that man has the biggest set of
Australian kangaroo nuts we've ever seen
my God
my God I know that's not he's definitely
a big Underdog that is a tough mother
Trucking fight man my God it's in person
that's in February yep hell yeah and one
of the rumors was it might not have
happened because they thought yair might
be the fighting uh makachev but then
yair is now fighting Josh Emmett Oh no
you're gonna say yair is going to fight
volkanovsky not mock Jeff Oreo I don't
know yeah yeah because they're at 45. so
now they're doing yair and Emmett for
the
what they call intern Bell which I'm not
intermedical especially guys going to
leave the division and go because who
knows what happens there so I'm cool
with that and then no matter what
happens with vocalypse you come back
it's belt for spelled bigger fight
another big fight for him but novc it's
so smart he's making all the money in
the world no matter what happens in the
market fight I think it's him
[ __ ] top fight for him right but who
knows you know he's on the feud for a
reason he's a Savage but um
Big Boy money the live gate on that uh
postcard the pay-per-view is going to be
massive and then let's say the odds
makers are right I'm not saying they are
right now I'll break down in February
but let's say the art makers are right
and vokanos are going to lose that fight
well then the downfalls fighting another
Super fight at 45 life is good if you're
volunovsky
and yeah Rodriguez Emmett that's great
fun great fight and thank God Josh got
his due you know he Josh Emmett would
have this probably would have happened
unless volkanasi decided to do the super
fight true so it's for him going up for
Josh Emmett the UFC was forced to yay
Rodriguez Josh Emmett
oh yeah what's interesting you know for
again for voknowski no matter what
happens in that mock Jeff fight he's a
huge favor over Eminem Rodriguez
he most likely eats those boys up you
know
I like all this I like dolls it's good
for all of them too take all my money
um let's go this I just saw on ESPN
ringside oh I love this so they ordered
WBC ordered Deontay Wilder versus Andy
gries
and that's gonna determine who's gonna
challenge Tyson Fury for his heavyweight
title that's so part of me wants it to
be wilder I'd love to see that again
right I really I want Joshua Fury but
I've given up on that as a fellow bread
well shout out to my Brits I know I
don't sound like one but I am half this
is really a great fight of wine gums and
I drink tea with milk be cool so
um Wilder Rooney's a great [ __ ] yeah
I'll tell you right now
tough fight for Wilder because here's
the problem Andrew Ruiz has no quit in
him he's not the guy where and it's not
that one shot might put Ruiz down Ruiz
might get dropped that kid does not stop
his pace and his combinations and the
volume punches that this dude that looks
like the fat kid from up grew up Mexican
and can box his ass off you know yeah
he's the fat kid from up but adopted by
a Mexican family put him in boxing right
this kid is a Savage quick hands don't
let the body fool you he is a Savage
look who I did to Anthony Joshua Joshua
overlooked him but still he got hit
Molly walked and the rematch right he I
just he got two
um big-headed he's partying I have
people close to Ruiz like dude he's out
all the time didn't take quite serious
which is insane because you beat him
Joshua you're getting the fury fights
and all that but you know things happen
he learned from it now he's with
canelo's team training
for Deontay Wilder for a guy where you
know he was down on the cards against
Luis Ortiz he beat him you know he
knocked him out
um I as a Wilder I love Wilder I've
worked with wilder many times one of my
favorite people in sports period I love
what the passion has he's a great
[ __ ] dad him and his girl great love
story Beauty and the Beast it's
fantastic
this is a tough fight for Wilder this is
a guy that doesn't have Quentin for
water a guy who was remember he's like
doing music videos didn't know if we're
gonna see him if he can retire
the problem is is when you're kind of
one foot in with it out which I don't
know if he is but I'm just saying if
there's any inclination where he's like
I don't know if I'm still gonna do this
Ruiz ain't the guy to fight because he
ain't gonna go easy that one shot ain't
gonna do it on him it's a great fight
yeah they say when it is next year yeah
just next year that's boxing
oh well sometime next year you know put
when [ __ ] UFC never does that
it's like Macha volkanovski maybe next
year
no you see they announced that [ __ ] you
got a date so we get crunk for it boxing
that's just old school like nah it's
okay
this is a controversial one
um so leading up to this fight stop
Bender he still he had shown a little
bit of that that breath yeah so this is
do you remind me there's nothing with
Izzy
there was no special walkout right like
it was all business which was a little
alarm even though I thought he performed
phenomenally
there was something to her I was like uh
I don't like that because he was relaxed
even though he's lost the guy twice and
one of them was a knockout but it was
like
his usual walkout the the entertainment
value like I was like my Square Garden I
couldn't wait I'm like what is he gonna
do and I didn't hear anything nobody
told anything about Izzy's walk out but
I figured you did something special so
this morning I would fast forward just
to the you know fight but with Izzy I'm
like I see the walkout and there's
nothing special you know when Bruce was
announcing he never did his cool you
know like anime whatever Pokemon [ __ ] it
is you did do he just you know he did
his whatever thing but there was no like
presentation which he's used to I'm like
oh that's interesting
that's interesting
that's not easy you know that's not
Disney we know I thought that was
interesting maybe she just took this
fight super serious which again he
showed out I'm not saying that's the
reason he lost I'm just saying like do
what gets you the day that's what makes
Izzy an outlier like he can perform
under all this pressure still go out
have his b boys out there do the
Undertaker walk out and still light
people up like is he's Beyond just the
fight itself but with this time and this
pressure I don't know he's serious I
don't like serious is it yeah even when
he was fighting he didn't look the same
he like he was just like yeah instead of
being like relaxed yeah but again you
know three out of four rounds he's doing
the damn thing and then that fifth round
so he's just like nah man I didn't feel
like doing it shut the [ __ ] up I'm like
yeah you look great it's over the fifth
round
so there's there's only one reason uh
the big questions return of Israel I
understand is very suspicious gyno so
this is from Faraz a hobby who's very
well respected for us training with him
for a number of years one of the most
Brilliant Minds to ever you know get in
the game
he's basically a Canadian
um it's almost uh disrespect to him
saying I was gonna say he's almost
Canadian Greg Jackson but Greg Jackson
doesn't have the fight experience that
for us does I mean for us you got to
talk about black belt and kickboxing
there's not such a thing I'm saying with
experienced black belt and kickboxing
black belt Jiu Jitsu literally molded
just being to what he is literally just
be Rory McDonald TriStar like man guys
he's Savage yeah so for him to make a
statement like this is you know
so he said this from uh uh foreign he
says I've been punching the chest I've
seen countless boxing rounds of them in
a glass big gloves I've seen countless
fights I've never I've never I've never
somebody get punched in the chest and
then have gyno I've never seen it now is
he saying that because that's what Izzy
says it's from I don't think he stands
for punch oh yeah yeah I understand the
guy walking the ring walk out with
inflamed breast or his next fight his
breast is inflamed because he got punch
in the chest never without making a
clear cut statement zabib seemingly went
in with theories that held many
observers who've thrown accusations that
Izzy so in my mind there's only one
reason for this there's only one group
that has this problem there's only one
group I just don't get it what other
possibilities could there be for me I
have no explanation I have no idea so I
was insinuating that it is you know
steroids I don't like when guys do this
you know I don't like when you guys do
this yeah the THC the we can lead to
some of that stuff uh I got a close
friend who just got straight up dude the
guy who have my car business with just
got diagnosed with uh breast cancer and
the lump in his breast as breast cancer
doesn't never get been hit in the chest
nothing sometimes these freak things the
problem is when you're as dominant as
Izzy we want to discredit a lot of his
stuff right it's just nature and and for
us isn't a hater I think for us thing is
just Why does he have that the guy's
this damn good it's easy to allude to
PDS right especially when you're a
world-class athlete because it's pretty
predominant and you know this level of
sports I just think with Izzy it's just
not the case I know Place more dates our
boy did it right and did he yeah Derek
said that
steroids would be the only cause every
wonder what you're talking about this
drastic endorsements the scientific link
between THC and gyno it's a real thing
yeah yeah
and that's what he's saying it's from
doing that's what it is he said yeah he
did that he said it before and another
thing said on uh the post five press
conference he was saying you know
Chadwick Boseman who died from yeah yeah
cancer and he was hitting he was hidden
from everyone he didn't tell anybody
right yeah so Izzy was saying something
like you know you don't know my story
you know he was referencing Chadwick
Boseman yeah people were super mean to
him yeah you talk about my thing you
know with my breasts you guys don't know
what happens behind the scenes like yeah
he's he's making it seem like there's
something more serious that's might be
going on with him too yeah that is right
and also I mean
this will be the near you know because
we're balls deep in MMA so we hear this
stuff but like the mainstream and then
it's nothing so it's some people to talk
about I don't like it I think it
discredits is these work and
um I also think
for us has been around the elite of the
elite and
I think we both know for a fact he's
probably some of the guys we've trained
with and fought with were on ship so
it's no knock on for us that's his
perspective but he said he had no idea
he's just he's like that's the only
thing he can think of but I don't know I
don't think he's fair just to jump to
that conclusion because that same thing
like calendar do this right like we'll
see a big guy like steroids right I'm
like I mean odds maybe you know maybe
but you never know it's not fair to do
because you know Tim Tebow was [ __ ] the
freak of all freaks my boy Joe cloth and
stuff I know a ton of guys that came up
playing football or finally have seen
they just they just built that way dude
unfortunately but if you don't have that
perspective you're like yeah but nine
out of 10 guys that I came up with were
on stuff I'm like I can get I conclude
of that I just don't like to do that
before Izzy's fight
like that's not the narrative
also if you want to go through the last
15 guys that Izzy fought you want to go
through their background
and he's you want to jump some
conclusion on some of them guys like
there's nothing to do with it either
where do you go there's a dead end Road
Izzy's never been popped that's the
thing he's never been popped he's test
all the time he's never been popped he's
a he's a you know one of the best ever
do it so it's it just it creates this
negative stigma is even for for what you
have literally have no proof yeah the
only proof you have is your confirmation
bias based off your experience of guys
that you've worked with so I think it
says more about who you've worked with
than is he
because a lot of guys he worked with you
thought it wasn't around back there
you make the correlation
uh I thought this was cool behind the
scenes is Francis and Garner talking to
Leon Edwards and you know Francis is
super close with Camaro Usman yeah Leon
obviously knocked me not so I'll play
this for you
okay thank you appreciate it
that's cool Leon brought up you know
what I like about Francis
when we had France on food truck I don't
know four or five years ago he was in
that same jacket
that's how because most people get money
get famed they don't wear anything twice
or whatever you know their thing yeah on
one of them he's wearing that same
jacket
the first time I met Francis I was at
the UC I don't know what the hell is
doing yeah he's in that jacket
CT my ass look at that memory Doug same
jacket
one million views holler at your boy as
far as getting suppressed on YouTube
um
same jacket yeah same jacket but most
people get rich and famous they get rid
of that stuff they're dressed and
different not my boy Francis man not my
boy Francis I know Comics who aren't
even that high level we won't wear the
same shoes twice on stage like how the
hell are you for in this man yeah
Francis just a good dude yeah assault of
the earth and still no
no agreement in sight nothing new going
on there you know I heard that's uh he
saw Dana White in the pi and they had a
good conversation but still nothing you
know what's weird to me on that is like
this shouldn't be like a drawn-out thing
like can't you guys just sit down like
it should be pretty upfront unless
there's just absolutely no deal just the
USC offered France is a deal he's like
nope
and then I guess what's holding it up is
maybe his team went back and UFC's like
let's think about it but shouldn't
somebody be thinking about it how why
does this drag out for months you know I
know the main thing he just wants and
not non-exclusive he wants to be able to
do two things obviously the boxing but
he also I know from for a fact he wants
to be able to do boxing first and then
John no no
no no did you go in there you get starts
by wild or Fury and then then we get
this damaged product and we're paying
you all this money he's asking for a lot
of money then you come fight Jon Jones
you lose that one then we're [ __ ]
we're paying this huge not guaranteed
contract I see both sides yeah I want to
see the Jones fight first and then 100
yeah 110 yeah
uh okay so I thought this was cool you
might have seen this already this is uh
Jake Paul when he first started training
and then versus how he is right now this
is cool to see
my God I know
that hook is atrocious it's just like
this he's all
Jesus Christ
yeah the kids put in work
that's super cool hate on no matter how
you feel about him as a personality
stuff hate on the word that's so bad
clearly clearly that's great yeah
uh your boy Cheeto Vera got a new tattoo
on his head I saw this let's take some
back and forth with him yeah that [ __ ]
had to hurt
that [ __ ] had to hurt I would love a
tattoo like down my neck though not on
my head
he's gonna throw your hair over it yeah
yeah you could some dude came to that
mean great that specs in Houston she's
got a fresh it was like a dove and
flowers but it was on the side of his
head oh man how's it going did it hurt
he's like dude he's like I was and I got
because it was like came down to his
Temple I'm like I bet that Temple was
[ __ ] horrible he's like now it's back
here man really like it feel in my brain
and it was like juicy and like taking
the picture I'm like holy [ __ ] that must
have hurt
there's a ton of blood vessels in your
head so that might make it worse
but it looks dope I'd love to get one
too
I don't know why you don't do it it's
not like you know I know you look sweet
man I know dude you're like damn
generally you accuse them I'll be sick
um let's see here I just got one more
then
this I thought was crazy Tony Ferguson I
guess he's gonna study business at
Harvard
good for it
good for him expanding his education now
is this like a uh who is it was it a
Blac Chyna uh was it uh Nicki Minaj was
that Harvard like there's Harvard right
and then there's Harvard online right
yeah I guess there's a picture of him
actually at Harvard I don't know what's
going on here to be honest but
let's see
hold on brother I'm studying faceless
reactors Tony Rosa Harvard for a
business degree
first of all if he is going to Harvard
shout out to Tony Ferguson if he got
into Harvard and this is what he's doing
and not fighting this is fantastic I
mean what a [ __ ] story
I just I don't know how you guys about
to write a thesis on CT [ __ ] haters
hilarious potatoes
uh the big hero of the spectrum between
the Fallen missed weight all right is
this it yeah hold on
uh he goes I'm already going back to
school for business in Harvard in about
a month and a couple of weeks actually
so I kept my word I'm keeping my word so
you guys he's gonna go back to school
yeah right now I'm going back to school
going for my business credentials from
Harvard and my buddy Lloyd and vitro
Belfort to help me with that after that
I'm going to go back to school and get
my PT so I'm gonna keep my word like I
always said I'm gonna go back gonna do
this [ __ ] I'm gonna do that [ __ ] don't
say [ __ ] though if you go to Harvard now
right it's like me going back to school
in college competing wrestling
that's dope if it's actually happening
for instance a big old school impossible
shifts to wrestling on his list of goals
which we spoke about prior to fight you
mentioned having a list of goals urged
everyone to list their goals and work to
achieve them
he doesn't have any plans for time from
MMA soon well if you're actually on
Harvard Business School we have to put
MMA on the back burner I don't know too
many people go to Harvard and also
compete in the UC at a high level
but God bless my man more power to him
that's lit yeah
all right so we would love to take some
Harvard classes online get one of those
digital degrees I'm not saying it's
about Tony's doing it sounds like he's
doing the real deal but I'm trying to do
that black China Harvard degree and then
Flex on my [ __ ] kids dude
oh Dad double this major from University
of Colorado also a little [ __ ] got a
degree from Harvard United you right
you're I decided you're sir or something
oh yeah yeah uh yeah I'm uh uh British
royalty yeah your royalty with a Harvard
degree yeah dude killing the kids got a
lot to live up to oh dad went to Harvard
yeah and then I'm just gonna you know
I'm gonna tell them how I got it yeah I
took seven classes online
Harvard I'm like yo you like Facebook a
little bit you like Instagram well you
know the guy who created that uh alumni
from my school
Zuckerberg you know we were thinking
about doing the app together back then
they just lied him just like we had an
app and then he stole it from me and
then I have a twin brother and we sued
him we won you should watch the movie
network anyway uh yeah UFC fights this
weekend you got a Fight Night some fun
fights on here you know it's not gonna
blow your dick away but it's a good card
uh Derek Lewis Sergey Spivak uh Derek
needs a win pretty bad I hope he gets
the win Cuda Libra is doing the damn
thing against Kennedy that's a great
fight too The Main Event comen Event
adolfo's back out against Cody J Sherman
they threw him on the card because his
car his fight fell out Andre fajio
um
yeah the prelim's a little tough but
um Danny Roberts fighting
Muslim yeah good good card solid card I
dear God I hope Derek Let's Get The
Knockout cute Libra is a problem too
then Adolfo is one of my favorites to
watch for a variety of reasons and then
there's a Bellator card it's not bad as
well the Bellator is fun so you got uh
Mega Madoff versus uh pitbull for the
lightweight Championship that's a great
[ __ ] fight I think uh no mega Madoff
wins that fight I think he's a slight
dog a theme was that fight Cranston
versus demkov great fight Corey doing
the damn thing since he left the UFC
left UFC I think right like fifth he's
going over to Bill Bellator doing the
damn thing he's on food truck when I was
still in the showtime but I think shot
of uh thick boy Studios he came on I was
just talking about how much you know he
you know he beat Jan he just laid out
and you look at his record like yeah
this guy has to be one of the best to
ever do it man his resume is impressive
and Tyler Fortune you know hoping he he
gets his [ __ ] together he's a Savage
good card man yep and this one I'm
excited for one Championship oh then you
also got uh is that that's Rockman
Junior versus Vitor Belfor as V tour
been posted on his Instagram getting
ready for this I don't know so that's
the thing let's let's take a look at his
and is this song Under trailer or some
[ __ ] I think the zone
doesn't look like anything here this
posting this kid who's a Savage for
years kids going
yeah Vito and uh Rumble
boys these train together black aliens
so who knows if this fight's still
happening but that's what I'm saying Oh
weird because he hasn't promoted it huh
interesting oh let's here it is oh there
it is
Ticketmaster
yeah tickets to the fight so
Saturday November 19th at 6 PM in Austin
Texas hell yeah damn that's in Austin
wow
and then you got one Championship baby
KFC and the main event's fun yeah so
yeah Cruiserweight yeah uh Joy Belton
who's I stream with him at ring
fantastic dude the Houston Alexander I
know old school bare knuckle Jesus
Christ he had the best body back in
those days right or one of the best
bodies you come out of the Nebraska
cornhuses gear
but yeah so one Christian Lee yeah
they're back on Prime baby he got Prime
this is the fourth fight it's in
Singapore again you got fights on Friday
you got fights on Saturday but they air
here at during prime time you have great
fights you got Christian Lee that's
Angela Lee's brother who's a Savage
um you got ratatang doing the damn thing
that's Muay Thai it's flyweight Muay
Thai and then also you got Cosmo
Alexander Cosmo if you're one Champion
uh fan he's the guy who starched our boy
uh North Sage Northcutt terrible fight
for sage North Carolina Cosmo is an
alien when it comes to Muay Thai this
dude is a Savage trained with my black
Dylan's nightmare fun to watch but
anytime uh Rada tang and Christian Lee
are fighting you need to get your
popcorn need to get your glass full of
some tiger thick whiskey sit down and
watch it it's on Amazon Prime and that's
Friday and Saturday you got two fight
cards you got championships you got two
championship fights you know badass
Russian for Christian Lee he got
freaking um you know ratatang doing the
damn thing and that's on Amazon Prime
it's the fourth one and they're airing
it prime time for the American audience
all right so make sure you guys go check
that out on Amazon we'll be posting too
if you more questions about it the
card's fantastic they always show out
nobody puts on production like one
Championship they basically have the guy
who was behind the scenes for for Pride
doing the the one Championship stuff so
the production is Second To None So my
favorite fights to watch I'll be
watching this in Milwaukee
because I'm in Milwaukee this Friday
Saturday only I have to do stuff on
Thursday so it's one of the rare
weekends I'm only doing two nights
Friday and Saturday only Milwaukee
Milwaukee improv is this Friday and
Saturday
um it's Jeffrey Dahmer's Hometown so I
will be doing tours because my black
belt and serial killers because I'm a
psychopath that is this Friday Saturday
November 18th and 19th in Milwaukee baby
uh please don't snow and then Providence
Rhode Island that is almost sold out we
might add some shows so if you want uh
tickets Providence Rhode Island December
1st through the third Province Rhode
Island and then I end the Ohi fake door
in Washington DC for this year
Washington sees my last tour date it's
December 15th through 17th DC
Improvement the best clubs in the
freaking country I can't wait I'm going
to the freaking uh I think it's the
Cosmos Pizza where pizza gate happens
with my favorite restaurants I'll be all
up and down that City hang out with
Biden it's a great time Kamala Harris
coming to the show Washington DC uh
Washington improv uh DC Improv December
15th 17th but Milwaukee Europe Friday
Saturday holler at your boy
um that's it because I thinkboy.com if
you want some of that award-winning
thick nectar we have it on thick boy
right now batch 2's available so it will
show up at yo doe step all right for
anything else merch all that stuff
bigboy.com whiskey thick boy.com enjoy
the fights
and
um we have a food truck hopefully you
guys enjoyed last week's food truck
where we had who do we have on we had Al
Joe one of my favorite food trucks it
was fantastic uh this week we're
dropping the Mike Perry one it's
fantastic so enjoy that thick boy uh
YouTube uh so we have thick boy YouTube
I have my friendship Comedy Channel I'm
drama new governor Abbott bit this week
on uh social media and on my Brennan job
YouTube comedy channel so make sure you
look out for that I love you guys be
safe
um that's it love you I'm out
this guide is known as a finisher
he'll choose to stand and bang with this
man they go to sleep
and I'm moving up the division
this man is an absolute monster in
welterweight
the biggest fight in welterweight
history
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding